die Toilette ja und das Lied
halt stopp Stopp Stopp Stopp ich habe
noch eine Wohnung gekauft ja dann
schauen wir uns die mal an jetzt kommt
die erste reaction ungefähr nach hautnah
dabei
[Musik]
ich sehe Fliesen im Badezimmer
[Applaus]
oh mein Gott es ist so perfekt
[Musik]
ich war schon mal in dieser Wohnung aber
das ist schon ein paar Monate her und
deswegen fühlt sich das alles an als ob
das gerade zum allerersten Mal ist und
falls ihr denkt dass meine Reaktion
vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben ist
ich habe zweieinhalb Jahre auf diesen
Moment gewartet okay also erstmal tolle
Bodenfliese haben wir gut ausgesucht
oder ich bin sehr zufrieden damit
[Musik]
die Fliesen tip top sehr gut ausgesucht
ich finde es auch cute dass das hier so
weißt du auf einer Höhe
oder findest du auch gut
schon so gefliest zu sehen ist heftig ne
okay ich will noch einmal den Rest
gucken ich habe gehört das ist auch
Parkett da weil das haben wir auch noch
nicht gesehen das haben wir nur
ausgesucht bis jetzt also
ich weiß nicht warum ich die ganze Zeit
so dramatisch bin aber dann wiederum
zweieinhalb Jahre
[Musik]
[Applaus]
Balkon oh der ist aber süß er ist ganz
klein also ich muss noch auf jeden Fall
bei Gardinen rein bevor ich einsehe das
halten ein bisschen heftig oder
ist das schon
weiß es wird noch verputzt und sowas
okay komm wir gucken uns einmal die
Parkett an
hier ist ein anderer als bei uns in der
Wohnung
ist schon heftig ne
und hier kommen auch noch hier sind ja
so kleine Fenster und hier kommt dann
auch so noch so eine kleine Fensterbank
dann kann ich so langsam
willkommen in der zweiten Wohnung die
ich gekauft habe ja ich habe euch jetzt
schon öfter davon erzählt dass ich mir
eine Wohnung gekauft habe aber es gab
von Anfang an eine zweite diese
verdammten Influenza und ihr Geld man
könnte schon denken das ist ein bisschen
übertrieben ist aber wozu könnte ich
eine zweite Wohnung gebrauchen es ist
eine Einzimmerwohnung und jetzt werde
ich sie als Büro benutzen was in Zukunft
damit passiert bin ich mir noch
überhaupt nicht sicher ich weiß jetzt
zwar nicht was die Zukunft bringt aber
ich weiß auf jeden Fall dass diese
Wohnung mit dabei helfen wird mich um
meine Altersvorsorge zu kümmern viele
Menschen wissen dass sie eine
Altersvorsorge brauchen aber die
wenigsten Menschen kümmern sich darum
oder ich werde dieses Jahr 30 bin
selbstständig und zahle nicht in meine
Rente ein klar schwebte mir auch mal so
der Gedanke im Kopf dass ich mich jetzt
so endlich meine Rente kümmern muss aber
ganz ehrlich mit Mitte 20 in der Blüte
meines Lebens habe ich diese Gedanken
auch gerne mal weggeschoben so im Sinne
von das hat ja noch Zeit aber je früher
man sich um seine private Altersvorsorge
kümmert umso weniger Sorgen wird man
später haben deswegen kommt jetzt
Werbung private Altersversorgung kommt
einem immer super kompliziert und lässt
sich vor aber Fakt ist einfach dass die
gesetzliche Rente nicht reichen wird und
sich zumindest über seine Möglichkeiten
zu informieren ist wirklich nicht
kompliziert vor allem nicht mit klar
klagt solltet ihr mittlerweile alle
kennen das ist ein digitaler
Versicherungsmakler der dir unter
anderem dabei helfen kann im Alltag gut
abgesichert zu sein dabei helfen dir die
unabhängigen versicherungsmaklerinnen
von Clark sie beraten Dich kostenlos und
persönlich im Chat per Videocall am
Telefon oder per Mail sie erstellen dir
ein unverbindliches Angebot wobei du
durch einen individuellen bedarfscheck
herausfindest welche Altersvorsorge zu
dir und deinen Bedürfnissen passt klar
kann man sich jetzt aber nicht um deine
private Altersvorsorge sondern alles
rund um das Thema Versicherung und das
geschieht alles digital in der App durch
das macht ja Mandat wird klar zu deinem
Versicherungsmakler und ist somit befug
sich um seine Verträge und Versicherung
zu kümmern dieses mag ja Mandat kannst
du jederzeit und kostenfrei wieder rufen
probier's einfach mal aus und versichere
dich ab und übrigens mit dem Code mal
wann erhältst du einen Shopping
Gutschein über 45 €, wenn du drei
bestehende Versicherungen auf Clark
überträgst dazu alle Infos in der
Infobox hier wird die Küche sein also
stellt Euch vor ich habe dann hier so
eine kleine Arbeitsplatte hinter mir ist
so eine cute Küche und ich drehe dann
hier meine Kochvideos und dann wird das
und wenn wir Cocktails machen oder sonst
was das wird alles hier stattfinden ich
bin mir auch noch nicht so sicher über
die Küche welche Küche ist am Ende sein
wird bleibt gespannt die Küche ist
eigentlich schon ausgesucht dann wenn
man so eine Wohnung baut dann braucht
man ziemlich schnell einen
kücheninstallationsplan damit die Leute
wissen wo sie die Rohre und Kabel und
sowas verlegen müssen ich bin aber
momentan mit der Küche die ich gerade
ausgesucht habe nicht 100% zufrieden und
gleichzeitig sind wir gerade mit einem
Hersteller im Gespräch über mögliche
Kooperationen zusammen und wenn das
klappt dann würde ich mich so freuen oh
mein Gott ich hoffe jeden Tag dass es
klappt weil dann freue ich mich so auf
die zukünftigen Videos und auf die Küche
und Alles was entsteht also könnt ihr
schon mal mit mit mir Daumen drücken ich
weiß ihr habt da nicht so viel davon
aber doch ihr habt dann gute Videos
davon ganz kurz ganz kurz hier ist dann
das zweite drehsetting
wo ich hier an dem Tisch arbeiten kann
und gefilmt werde ja das ist fast it so
da kommen noch Schreibtische hin dass
wir auch arbeiten können hier
wahrscheinlich da muss man wirklich mit
dem Platz schauen ne weil diese Wohnung
das ist eine Einzimmerwohnung ich glaube
es sind hier 36 Quadratmeter und da muss
man halt wirklich gut wird mit seinem
Plan ja und
dann kommen wir mal zu dieser Ecke das
wird einfach nur Stauraum also hier
kommt ein großer Schrank hin jetzt so
geplant und dann wird alles nur voll
gemacht mit unseren ganzen Technik mit
den Kostümen mit Requisite
hier werden Steckdosen passieren
und hier wo ich eben gerade schon so
krass reagiert habe wird das Badezimmer
sein und ich hoffe dass ich hier auch so
ein bisschen Halt filmen kann und machen
kann und ja ich finde es total cute ich
bin mir noch überhaupt nicht sicher über
die Deko ich glaube ich will
irgendwelche Tapeten haben ich will hier
so ein bisschen bunt Leben Lifestyle
einbinden hier kommt das Waschbecken hin
hier kommt die Toilette hin könnt ihr
euch das vorstellen Hammer
und hier ist die Badewanne
die Fliesen haben wir so gut ausgesucht
achso die auch
die sind auch gut ne
[Musik]
was kommt da
ach für den Heizkörper ne hier kommt der
Heizkörper hin ja stimmt oder komme ich
da
hin ja hier mache ich dann noch so einen
kleinen Schminktisch
ja that's it das ist jetzt der Baustelle
mein ursprünglicher Plan war es gar
nicht meine private und berufliche
Wohnung voneinander zu trennen wir haben
Ende 2020 angefangen nach einer Wohnung
zu schauen denn nach Corona oder
mittendrin in Corona wurde uns langsam
klar dass die Zinsen die ja so niedrig
waren bei den Banken wahrscheinlich
nicht mehr lange so bleiben werden und
deswegen wurde ich ein bisschen panisch
und dachte mir jetzt müssen wir jetzt
langsam was finden also habe ich mich
auf die Suche gegeben und dann habe ich
eine Wohnung gefunden ich glaube sie
hatte damals oder sie hatte 130 oder 140
Quadratmeter und wir haben sie gesehen
und dachten das ist die perfekte Wohnung
ich weiß 130 bis 140 Quadratmeter klingt
mega viel ihr dürft aber nicht vergessen
dass Timo und ich mein Partner und ich
beide Vollzeit von zu Hause aus arbeiten
und beide nicht nur ein Schreibtisch
brauchen sondern halt auch Equipment
Requisiten ähm timo hat total viel
Technik und ich habe total viel Technik
wir brauchen den Platz
gesagt dann haben wir einen Termin
bekommen ich war so happy dass wir uns
das überhaupt anschauen konnten weil
also damals und das ist ja heute
wahrscheinlich sogar noch schlimmer das
ist jetzt fast der 3 Jahre her das ist
drei Jahre her habe ich dann gemerkt wie
krass teuer Wohnung sind ich meine das
ist nichts Neues und deswegen war auch
die Auswahl an Wohnungen die wir uns
überhaupt leisten könnten war halt
ziemlich gering und ähm klar es gab
tolle leere Wohnungen für 1,5 Millionen
Euro in Mitte oder in Friedrichshain
oder sonst wo naja und dann haben wir
halt eine Wohnung gefunden wo wir
wirklich gesagt haben die ist von der
Größe und von allem drum und dran
perfekt ich meine das ist ein Kauf das
ist ne mal irgendwo einziehen und wieder
ausziehen das geht ja noch irgendwie
naja und dann sind wir halt in dieses
Büro gefahren und der Mann hat uns
gesagt dass sie den Tag vorher
reserviert wurde also ich glaube man
muss sogar was bezahlen ja ich glaube
wir haben auch für unsere Reservierung
was bezahlt naja dann bezahlst du
reservierst du und dann ist es erstmal
und wir hatten keine Chance die zu
kriegen und ich saß da wirklich also
weil ich kam so richtig happy rein habe
mich so hingesetzt und meinte so ja wir
wollen mal drüber sprechen ne hier
Wohnung kaufen wir wussten ja auch gar
nicht was auf uns zukommt ja dann guckt
er mich so an so welche noch mal ja nee
die gibt's nicht dann bin ich wirklich
von so hier oben auf so gesunken so wie
die traurig geguckt ich habe nicht mal
gemeckert oder so weil also was soll ich
denn meckern aber sie haben doch gesagt
dass bringt ja nichts und dann guckt er
uns an und du merkst so ein bisschen so
ja hier ist eine Wohnung ähm ich zeig
dir ihn mal und dann habe ich diese
gesehen und dachte mir sowas auch tolle
Wohnung aber ich glaube knapp 100
Quadratmeter aneinander gesagt ja das
ist halt aber zu klein also wir brauchen
ja wirklich Platz und wir haben jetzt
hier
ich glaube 112 Quadratmeter und das ist
uns schon einfach zu wenig also wenn ihr
jetzt gerade bei 50 Quadratmeter lebt
und denkt WoW oder 112 Quadratmeter das
ist so ein Palast nicht wenn man beide
von zu Hause lebt ich dachte auch damals
dass wir hergezogen sind ja das ist doch
gut von der Größe weil wir davor auf 60
oder 70 Quadratmeter gelebt haben aber
es ist immer noch ein Ticken also es
steht einfach noch zu viel rum und dann
sagt er so naja gut aber ähm was machen
was planen Sie denn dann so ja aber
sowas und dann zeigt er so und mein Sohn
na ja aber hier wäre noch eine ein
Zimmer Wohnung und ich guck so und bis
dahin habe ich nie gedacht irgendwie ja
so ein extra also eine zweite Wohnung zu
kaufen weil ganz ehrlich erste Wohnung
zu kaufen ist schon so krass über mein
Vorstellung gewesen naja und dann habe
ich diese zweite gesehen habt ihr gesagt
gut also eigentlich warum nicht und ja
dann haben wir so darüber gesprochen
haben so ein bisschen die Preise
zusammengerechnet was ist denn dann am
Ende zusammen kosten würde und ob das
mit der anderen Wohnung ob das immer
noch so diesem Rahmen ist den wir uns
überlegt hatten und es hat dann gepasst
und dann haben wir reserviert und ab
dann war es klar ich werde eine eigene
bürowohnung haben was glaubt mir meine
Engine noch mal so krass gestiegen hat
aber ich bin froh dass ich Team oder an
meiner Seite habe weil er mir wirklich
noch mal so diesen diesen sicheren Halt
gibt und diese Worte die man auch
manchmal braucht wenn man sich gerade
etwas nicht traut zu sagen hey wir
kriegen das hin es gibt gerade ja bei
Immobilien klar man vergisst ja immer
diese ganzen Notar Kosten und dann
wollen wir diesen Boden und nicht diesen
dann wollen wir auch noch extra Fliese
da dann kommen noch Küchen dazu dann
willst du vielleicht ein anderes
Waschbecken oder andere Toilette Dusche
was auch immer und dann noch neue Möbel
vielleicht weil die anderen nicht
richtig passen oder sowas da kommt schon
ganz schön viel zusammen aber trotzdem
meinte er halt hey nee wir können Sie
immer noch verkaufen wir können immer
noch irgendwie so ein Schritt zurück
machen ne das hast du gesagt oder hast
du gesagt ne dass das wir immer alles
sicher sind ne ich rede gerade über
unseren Wohnungskauf ja und jetzt habe
ich diese Wohnung und und stell dich mal
vor ich mache morgens auf und ich gehe
nicht einfach nur ins nächste Zimmer
sondern ich ziehe mich an Mami
vielleicht ein bisschen frisch und dann
gehe ich rüber in meinem Büro Wohnung
und dann schließe ich auf mach mir
vielleicht einen Tee oder ein
koffeinfreien Kaffee setz mich dahin
vielleicht erstmal in mein Laptop
vielleicht ist mal so im Büro arbeiten
machen vielleicht schon den Dreh
vorbereiten wie krass das wäre deswegen
also ich glaube die Zukunft meiner
Videos wird spannend ich bin noch
gespannt wegen Adventskalendern also
weil ich komme da wahrscheinlich rein im
Oktober dieses Jahres und ich weiß nicht
also wie das so laufen wird ich also ich
will Adventskalender Videos machen so
wie jedes Jahr ich bin nur gespannt wie
ich das hinkriege weil der mittendrin
ist in dem ganzen Wahnsinn und dann
schauen wir mal was die Zukunft bringt
ich war jetzt die letzten Monate ich
weiß dass es keinen Geheimnis sagt es
auch sogar die Zahlen und so ich will
mich davon eigentlich nicht zu sehr
verrückt machen weil es sind am Ende nur
Zahlen aber die Zahlen repräsentieren
schon ganz gut wieder wie ich mich auch
in den letzten Monaten gefühlt habe was
mein Content angeht also es ist das
erste Mal seit langem dass ich so ein
bisschen das Gefühl hatte hey ich habe
nicht so diese richtige Motivation okay
was ist das nächste Video und was kommt
dann dann als nächstes und deswegen
brauche ich unbedingt dieses Büro und
diesen Umzug und alles ich glaube ich
brauche mal wieder so ein richtig
frischen Wind der mir einmal so durch
die Haare weht und ich bin einfach
gespannt was die Zukunft bringt und wenn
alles den Bach runtergeht ihr werdet als
erstes erfahren spätestens wenn ich dann
nicht mehr im Büro bin aber ich kann so
viele tolle Sachen damit machen
ja gut also ich könnte den Airbnb daraus
machen und vermieten das sind die ganzen
tollen Sachen oder ich mache einen Arzt
ich werde vielleicht endlich mal
Künstlerin und das wird mein Atelier
ganz bestimmt okay Leute wir sehen uns
dann das nächste Mal wieder ich bin
jetzt völlig aufgedreht und hungrig und
ich hoffe euch hat das Video gefallen
und ich hoffe ihr könnt euch ein
bisschen für mich mit freuen ich weiß es
ist super scheiß Zeit irgendwie ich also
die Inflation auch wenn man es kaum
glauben mag die hättet mich auch ich bin
jedes Mal schockiert wenn ich im
Supermarkt bin und ich will eigentlich
nicht aber so negative Themen reden und
gleichzeitig will ich aber auch fühle
ich mich komisch wenn ich euch erzähle
hey ich habe eine zweite Wohnung gekauft
mir geht's so prächtig ich hoffe ihr
könnt euch trotzdem für mich freuen und
ähm wenn nicht dann habt ihr bestimmt
euren Grund und den will ich euch gar
nicht wegnehmen und ich habe euch ganz
lieb und wir sehen uns dann das nächste
Mal wieder und bis dann das nächste
Video wird auch wieder fantastisch ich
habe da ganz toll und das übernächste
Video oh mein Gott ich habe Neuigkeiten
für euch
große Neuigkeiten noch größer als die
wir sehen uns ne tschüssi